volcanoes elemental weapons tanks and
the eternal battle between fire and ice
let's talk about fortnight season 8
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's my favorite time of the fortnight
cycle the week before the new season
begins and we all get on the hype train
and look for signs leaks and hints
behind the future of fortnight I've
looked through the countless theory
videos and kept an eye on those leakers
allowing us to predict season 8 content
we have a pretty great track record
behind us we've predicted llama headed
characters as zombies a castle a
completely snow filled map overpowered
melee weapons and even a bright pink
hamster so let's see if we can do it all
over again let's start with what we know
100% by using the loading screens and
map evolution to build a storyline can
you remember all the way back to the
start of season 7 the iceberg hit our
beloved island bringing a snow biome as
the week's continued we saw a thawing
medieval castle in the snow atop of
polar peak as the thawing continued the
ice king was awakened and attempted to
stop his home from melting through a
live event sadly for the Vanilla Ice Ice
Baby King he was too late and deep in
his dungeon a new character awakened his
skin resembled volcanic rock and as we
upgraded his attire the dungeon prisoner
was revealed to be the ice King's
nemesis the yin to his yang signifying
the new battle between fire and ice if
you see my easter egg breakdown of
season 7 you know that I talk about the
Lich King story from World of Warcraft
which has many similarities to season 7
story arc I'm not going to go through
that here but I do recommend you have a
watch of that but the biggest clues to
season 8 and right in front of our eyes
in the battle personales
back in season 5 a crazy castle spray
foreshadowed both the castles at Haunted
Hills and now the one at polar Peaks
the bus'll pass has also foreshadowed
character skins like the wrestler or
even the shark glider so we know it's a
good place to get hints now look at this
season's battle pass and this unlockable
icon it's of a broken
Gockel telling us two months in advance
that someone would be unleashed
during season seven and at this point
you know that's the prisoner and from
memory can you think of the only place
we've seen this shackle before it's here
in plain sight it's on the dark bombers
boobs it's on the dark bombers chest and
to compound this the loading screen
unlocked literally next to the shackles
depicts the devilish Lama and his
shackle but look in the background it's
a volcano I know it's not set in stone
puns but the polar opposite of an
iceberg must be a volcano right this
theory looks even more certain with the
recent inclusion of earthquakes as magma
attempts to burst through the Earth's
crust
it causes movement in the landscape and
judging by the location of all the
earthquakes thus far this spot right
here looks like the birthplace of Vinnie
the volcano
yeah named him from Garen pod and look
at the placement it would be at the
opposite corner from the Ice King
perfect for two team buses to drop at
each corner representing their chosen
leader or deity I'm team fire King all
the way who would you choose in the
Battle of Fire and Ice well I can
actually go deeper into this theory
are you ready have you noticed that epic
game has its finger on the pop-culture
pulse seasonal event timing football
gear or soccer gear to coincide with key
dates in the season heck they even
released a dragon pet to coincide with
Spyro the Dragon re-releasing and of
course timed crossover events like
Thanos his inclusion and the Easter Egg
for wreck-it Ralph - well probably the
biggest TV event of the year is about to
happen Game of Thrones Season 8 which
begins in April this series is about
White Walkers who follow a king of ice
known as the night King and on the other
side of the battle we have Daenerys the
queen who controls dragons and without
jumping to too many conclusions dragon -
breathe fire write the book series that
the TV show is based on so happens to be
called A Song of Fire and Ice and to
perfectly time this the coming season
when it returns we'll be season 8 just
like fortnight season 8 this must be too
much of a coincidence but what do you
think
and the final point to confirm this
theory those dragon eggs in the castle
dungeon have now vanished they've
disappeared in the TV show when these
bad boys hit fire they hatch
and what has the prisoner spent the last
three weeks doing unleashing his fire
powers okay I'm starting to get hyped
season 8 could be epic of course let's
not put all our dragon eggs in one
basket there's other things to consider
another highly regarded concept for
season 8 is one of melted snow a
potential flood something as simple as
the ice cube known as greasy Grove
melting the area would be flooded
instead and since loot lake was ripped
apart the pool of water could be added
somewhere else this would also tie into
water-themed skin such as the divers the
shark glider and this freak of a
character fish sticks he's such a
strange inclusion that maybe he would
represent a new mechanic in the game
underwater battles may be the battle Paz
continues to hint at this direction -
with fish sprays and an octopus at tier
84
looking reminiscent of good old Davy
Jones or maybe we'll see the Kraken in
the oceans around the map although I
love the concept and the great skins
people have put forward like this
Poseidon character by Bishop Usha that's
a quality name by the way it seems
unlikely to me mainly because things
that travel over to Battle Royale have
usually previously been tested in save
the world the hoverboards the TV station
the crater all began life can to save
the world portion of the game so with
this in mind I jump back in to save the
world for the first time since defeating
the storm king who by the way was
actually kevin the cube i look for
places here that haven't been included
in battle royale we have a wild west
location with saloons and rustic vibes
but even though calamity made it into
battle royale her town did not well not
yet anyway and if we remember back a few
seasons alica proclaimed that the motel
would become a saloon in season 6 so
there are definitely links to both game
modes even though they're a bit
convoluted one of the mechanics added
last season save the world were these
well wings they were essentially baby
tornadoes hurricanes cyclones whatever
you prefer
well those lovely leakers have noticed a
file named tornado meaning we could see
this happen in season 8 he's technically
already been here when Kevin took the
loot lake house for a tour of the island
so it won't be a new mechanic but a
returning mechanic to compound this
theory further take a look at the week
11 loading screen the prisoner regains
his fire powers and the flames beside
him do appear to be whirling
come on guys fight hurricane confirmed
hit the alley eh music hmm sorry that
was very toxic of me as we're talking
about those little liquors though look
at a few things they've uncovered the
map change will affect the colour of
wailing woods everything looks to be
brown sort of burnt this could back up
any of our previous theories maybe the
ground burns for weeks before the
volcano erupts or maybe the flame
tornado first takes out the plant life
around wailing woods both completely
feasible more leaks have shown us where
the earthquake will hit in the future
and you've guessed it tilting towers the
most unlucky building site in the world
will return to rubble
unless epic is trolling us and I think
soon they'll start misleading us to keep
a few surprises up their sleeves
do you mind if I take a quick moment to
immortalize these legends on screen
these guys use my support to create
occult and amaru in the shop and then
sent me an image via Twitter if you want
the shout out I'd be honored to do so
you guys you're awesome don't change
midway through the season two skins
released paradox and lace did you notice
the symbol on their shirts the figure
eight depicted by a dragon eating its
own tail is this another coincidence
or is this foreshadowing to the Dragons
coming in season eight to throw a little
Egyptian and Norse myth in for good
measure the serpent or dragon eating
their own tail is very interesting and
yet again ties into our theories the
original image represents the
relationship between the Sun God rah and
the pact with the god of the underworld
Osiris basically good versus evil fire
versus the Dark Void of Ice in Norse
myth you know the place where kratos and
boy have just visited they have a
serpent instead called your man gander
who grew so big he could wrap himself
around the world twice just like a
figure of 8 this could all be
foreshadowing for future narrative if
you remember when the leaker who
formerly worked for Epic Games confirmed
the inclusion of the Egyptian pyramid it
never actually appeared could a future
event take us back in time as the dragon
eating its own tail suggests you know
what I think I'm going down this rabbit
hole a bit too much it's just a logo on
a shirt
get a grip Adam Oh before I forget what
do you think will happen with the hatch
bunkers in wailing woods and the icy
island I like the theory of a portal
between the snow and ice areas
some people also think we'll get an
underground railway both sound epic epic
so you can take both these ideas
okay my last point is so surreal but
it's brilliant as I'm writing this a
tank has been introduced at the block of
course it's a building not a real tank
but that's my point
I believe tanks are coming let me
explain as I've said earlier I've played
a bunch of save the world to get to the
storm king rest in peace Kevin during
this journey a key plot point
soraa's discover a secret bunker kinda
like the ones at wailing woods inside
out of these bad boys
tanks they are simply too great not to
become a real asset in battle royale
fortnight developers have openly stated
they wish to include more travel options
in battle royale to include new fight
mechanics could a tank be one of them
the asset is already here it's in place
ready to go so they just need to
foreshadow it some way like having a
big-ass tank at the block I'm likely
reaching a bit too far for Season eight
but I personally guarantee tanks will
begin battle royale one day you mark my
words
pretty please epic games are I look
pretty stupid right now going back into
the castle walls we can see where the
elemental gods had their disagreement
the emblem of fire is on the chair
tossed to the ground before he was taken
to the dungeons the other chairs have
the emblems of earth wind and water or
in this case it's ice we've now seen the
Ice King and we know about the
whereabouts of the fire king but what
about the other three
well the ether would actually link to
Kevin the cube and the Storm King who
controlled reality but that means we are
still waiting to learn of the earth or
air kings or queens come on people
opportunities for our fictional godlike
monarchs likely the air queen blew the
wind to make the iceberg crash we'll
have to see if this narrative is taken
forward it sounds really interesting to
earn a full team of deities we could
call them the God Squad no okay
[Music]
and finally I'm going to make a big
prediction which I cannot back up in the
slightest elemental weapons should our
theory about ice versus fire be correct
it's likely the weapon from save the
world which harness those effects will
make it into the Battle Royale realm
epic have tested the fire effects for a
few seasons now with the latest edition
those interactive campfires across the
world if the fire tornado has any basis
the flame effect will be present this
will also help with weapon cycling have
you noticed how the same weapons seem to
release often we have four types of
shotgun and we recently got another
hunting rifle style weapon the constant
adding of weapons keeps us all on our
toes but this process will be much
easier if they include some from save
the world even as a limited time mode
these will revolutionize gameplay so
yeah I think now is the time am i onto
something or am i talking but uh but
please let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below my voice
is starting to go so I hugely appreciate
your time and I adore having these types
of conversations I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
as always I'll see you in season eight
[Music]
just use kodada Maru in the fortnight
shop I need some new underwear help a
brother out